the conclusion of Black Adam leaves its
characters in very interesting places
for future dceu movies but what about
Pierce Brosnan's Dr Fate the following
contains spoilers for Black Adam besides
Dwayne Johnson's Sound Stage shaking
frame filling most of the scenes of
Black Adam the hierarchy of power in the
DC Universe hasn't so much as changed as
it has spread out with the addition of
the Justice Society of America besides
marking the first big screen iteration
of Black Adam the film also marks the
arrival of the classic super team this
iteration features Carter Hall AKA
Hawkman Cyclone Adam Smasher and the
stoic Dr Fate played by Pierce Brosnan
in Black Adam it's established early on
that both Carter and the good doctor
also known as Kent Nelson go way back
the Wise Old Mystic is much older than
he appears living a life riddled with
harrowing visions of Bleak Futures that
he's thankfully managed to avoid my
vision has shown me the future however
The Reawakening of an ancient Force
paves the way for a fate that not
everyone will be able to outrun leading
Nelson to drastic steps to avoid it now
with the dust settled what's Dr Fate's
prognosis and what does it mean for the
future of the dceu on the verge of
making a comeback if you've got this far
you've no doubt checked Black Adam off
your watch list and seen that Brosnan's
Charming master of magic sacrificed
himself to get Black Adam back in the
fight it's a bit of a shame the former
Bond's involvement in the franchise was
so brief after being considered a
highlight following the film's release
all that's left now is an empty chair on
Carter Hall's Decked Out Cruiser and a
helmet without an owner Well for now at
least in the comics the helmet of Fate
has had many owners over the years with
Nelson being one of its most notable
even those not explicitly chosen to Dom
the helm have tried on the headgear
including dry wooded hellblazer John
Constantine and even Superman himself on
some occasions however the helm has been
a perfect fit for other Heroes donning
the mantle of Dr Fate Nelson's own
bloodline has stepped up to take over
and there have even been total newcomers
to the game of good evil and hand-wavy
magic spells however among those
contributing to Fate's Legacy is a
contender that given a little bit of
tweaking here and there could be located
not far from Adam's home turf currently
in the comics the doctor on duty isn't
Kent Nelson but his nephew Khalid
masseur debuting in 2015 Khalid is an
Egyptian American who has been linked to
many of DC's super teams Beyond just the
Justice Society currently he's a member
of justice league dark a United Force
against the Demonic and hellish threats
to humanity and led by none other than
John Constantine considering the
character is set to return to the big
screen with Keanu Reeves reprising the
role it feels almost like fate that the
next in line for that Shiny Gold helmet
is part of a team that Warner Brothers
has been wanting to bring to live action
for years with Constantine coming back
to exercise some demons and a helmet
without a hero to Don It Black Adam
feels like a great stepping off point to
establish another new area of the DC
Universe that is fighting to make a
comeback also given khalid's Egyptian
Heritage it'd be cool if his origin
story could be altered and he somehow
winds up in conduct to meet Black Adam
just like his Uncle did who knows the
high hierarchy of power in the DC
Universe might be changing after all and
it could become the perfect prescription